he is calling tonight's game here in los
angeles on
espn the final game of the first round
of the play-in tournament that is new
for all of us
including the long-time nba head coach
and espn
nba analyst jeff van gundy how are you
jeff van gundy
doing fine how are you i am doing well
let's uh before
we're getting into tonight what you
thought
of last night's affair uh tatum dropping
50 on the wizards to set up
the wizards hosting the pacers who blew
the doors off the hornets what'd you
think of last night's action
i thought the pacers looked really good
and obviously tatum was great
it's interesting tatum had 50 but it's
not it's not counted in regular season
stats and it's not counted
in playoff stats so what is it like
i i don't understand how that can't be
construed as a playoff game
yeah i'm i'm with you jeff i don't
understand like so
why are we not calling that a playoff
game i mean exactly
like they're if they if they're in the
playoffs now so if they didn't win
they wouldn't be in the playoffs i i
it's got to go somewhere it can't
you can't have a records set
in just a new category called play-in
records that can't be
what we want so um anyway but i i
thought i thought indiana looked
terrific
i thought uh boston even though they've
had
you know these injuries you know it
shows just how dangerous they can be
in a one-game setting now i don't think
they have a chance necessarily
to upset new uh brooklyn but i
i was so impressed with how tatum played
how kimball walker played
they were excellent yeah they combined
for 79 points last night
and you know i guess we we can
eventually talk about what boston versus
the nets looks like and we can assume
what
certainly minus jaylen brown looks like
but before we get to that uh
it's just you know his statistics
regardless of whether their regular
season
playoff or state farm playing tournament
maybe that's what it is uh jeff the the
record goes into a state farm book
somewhere
um so what what do you make of westbrook
the numbers you know hey you got a
double double 20 and 14 but
you watch the game and it's just like
that that is so
not bringing your a game to an a game
required moment
mostly once again for him
they i think washington did a really
good job of getting to the eighth seed
and the difference between eight and
nine is obviously
all you have to do is win one game to
get in the playoffs so
they didn't play well last night uh the
wizards as a whole but particularly the
two best players
uh westbrook and beale but they get
another shot at it
um and so it'll be interesting you know
playing at home
you know how do they respond i would i
would suspect
they would play well and uh no one's
more injured than
indiana it's even hard to know who's in
their starting lineup
uh but they played a heck of a game
really good on offense
uh so bonus is terrific they're gonna
have their work cut out for them
but i think you know the wizards will
bounce back
play a much better game and they're
going to have to if they're going to
beat indiana
so uh just i guess writ large once again
russell westbrook's game
in the playoff i i guess when he was up
3-1
against the warriors when he was a
teammate of durant was the club
is his high water mark of his of his
playoff
career one would say um
does he i'll just point blanket does he
shrink in the big games
do you think russell westbrook i don't
know i thought he played uh
like i'm trying to remember back was a
game four in the finals against miami
that he was
so very good um i'm forgetting now
exactly the game but
i don't think it's necessarily he
shrinks i think he has a
uh uh a game that is high risk high
reward
you know he's not a great shooter he'll
take some risk
uh with his passing so sometimes he has
big turnovers
but he makes uh some incredible plays to
sometimes offset those you know
strengths uh and and i think overall
the the teams that have him uh
win at a pretty high rate so i think um
you know he's an interesting guy i don't
think he's
i i don't get it wrapped up in
the triple doubles and like that that
does not mean as much to me as it does
to some i i just like to use my eyes
uh and watch and i think overall
he has a very positive impact on really
every team that i've seen him play for
and that doesn't mean there's not ups
and downs
or or things that you wish maybe he did
a little bit better shoot it more
consistently
but overall you get a good effort from
him every night
uh he cares deeply about winning and his
his teammates and his coaches
and that for a great player is not
always
the case so uh i really respect him
and what he's been able to accomplish
jeff van gundy here
on the rich eisen show what are you
looking forward most to seeing tonight
between the lakers and the warriors you
call in this game
well i think the lakers are obviously
the much better team when healthy i
think
steph curry has the superpower to carry
any team in a given night so i'm really
interested to watch how the best team
uh defensively in our league
defends curry through the regular season
they've defended him very well
uh they're big uh they're smart
and i'm gonna be i'm really interested
in that
and if he can't have one of those
you know super power knights is wiggins
good enough
to go get 25 to 30 tonight
uh so that they'll have a chance to
score enough to win
so is the mvp playing in this game
tonight
for you
[Music]
you know one thing i would say is
like i don't vote on those awards
because i don't see like every team
enough to
say that's the guy but i'll i do believe
this about curry
there is absolutely no player more
valuable to his
team than steph curry is to the warriors
so you could be as valuable you could
vote and and
and make a a serious case for jokic
and he's had a remarkable year but when
i watch the warriors
i'm i think i'm looking at a guy who's
as
valuable to his team as any player that
i remember
in basketball i i just
have a difficult time again um
saying that jokic is the
mvp because of what the nuggets did
with him and what he did for them and it
is remarkable
with the injury of jamal murray
occurring and what he did after that
because that and but curry doesn't you
know get the
credit for being most valuable
based on the fact that he didn't have
klay thompson he knew that from
jump and that so i can't i can't compare
the two now you could sit here and say
yokitch's team
was 22 games above 500 and that's a
different story
and you know obviously the warriors are
in a playing game in that sort of nether
world of of a playing game tonight
that's that that the argument
i can't square that argument jeff van
gundy that's the one i have a problem
with
yeah i don't think you have to like
people i know there's people out there
who
look at numbers and you know they'll
come up with these
what they call advanced stats and and
you can call them that or you can call
them bs
like i you know i i think you can make a
case for a lot of it
right but when you're talking about
curry
i think this is the best
and most powerful i've ever seen him
at helping a team dramatically
overachieve
it's not just the numbers he puts up
it's the gravity he draws to himself
that opens up
opportunities for the complementary
players that they have
that are okay but certainly not
you know stand out complimentary players
but because of his greatness attracting
so much attention
and how he plays the game off the ball
it generates
such high quality shots for the other
guys
comparatively to what they could get
when he's not in the game
that i think that has been a little bit
overlooked
and uh and that is not to diminish jokic
at all like
jokic if you vote for him like that's
that makes sense there there's no
question he's had
a great year and he's done for
the nuggets what curry does for the
warriors which is
they play great even when guys are out
with injury because
he's that good and he is certainly the
best passing big men
i've seen since walton and sabonis
uh i mean he is a fabulous fabulous
passer
jeff van gundy here on the rich eisen
show as monty williams
chris paul and the rest of the sons sit
at home
tonight and watch you and the rest of
the espn
crew broadcast this game who do you
think they're rooting for
i know that they'll play whoever they
got to play etc and so on and so forth
i'm sure they're rooting for the
warriors you know
they're not going to say that but it
would make sense the warriors aren't as
good a team
and i don't even know like this idea we
don't want to give them any bulletin
board
material guess what like the warriors
know
the sons want them to win and the sons
want the warriors to win does that mean
that it would be a walk over of a series
absolutely not but
it would give them a better chance to
win in the first round
but i like the whole sun's attitude
whoever we play we're not going to try
to manipulate
by dropping games we're going to play
who's in front of us because our goals
are we gonna beat everybody so we're
gonna play who's ever in our path
and i think that mindset is a
championship mindset i think it gives
them
uh the the right attitude going into the
playoffs regardless of who they end up
playing but they
certainly would rather face the warriors
well i mean there was such a
conversation over the last uh
you know weekend that the the clippers
and ty lue
uh purposefully lost the last two games
to avoid being
in the part of the bracket that sees the
lakers uh prior to
a western conference final and you know
ty's saying i don't care what people say
i don't read twitter snapchat or
whatever whatever he says
but um what about the idea that you want
to get the lakers now like right now
before
where there might be some doubt in their
heads that there is
still maybe lebron not a hundred percent
as he says he'll never be that way again
like
what about the concept getting them now
go for it first thing right out of the
gate well i
i think rich it's like i agree with
everybody
i agree with ty lou he shouldn't care
what anybody else thinks
he has to make decisions that are in the
best interest of the team
whatever he feels those are then people
who are judging those decisions
have every right to say i think it's
weak what they did
and that they are trying to they're not
necessarily like
strategizing health this is about
avoidance
like the you know and i thought you can
agree with i agree with both people like
i agree that ty lue he should do what he
feels gives them their best chance
i also agree that the media shouldn't be
constrained from
judging what the decisions are but i do
believe that clippers
have the best talent in the western
conference i don't even think it's
particularly close
now i thought that last year as well and
they didn't play as well in those last
three games against denver as they would
have wanted to
so i'm interested to watch how they
played this year in the playoffs
are they are they stealed a little bit
from that failure last year
or that and i shouldn't say failure
disappointment last year
um are their best players gonna play
their best when their very best is
needed uh when it gets into the
nitty-gritty
of these close playoff games see those
things to me
um mean a lot more when you have the
best team
than who you actually play in the first
round like if i was the clippers myself
i would i wouldn't worry about i would
just try to be playing well
before i wouldn't worry i'm the best
team i'm not worried if it's
uh la or golden state or whoever it's
going to be
denver dallas ah i feel i'm better
and we're gonna we're gonna rock when it
when it comes time to play and play well
and knowing that in the western
conference everybody's good
so you're not getting like a break no
matter who you play it's not like
dallas with doncic if they're healthy is
any
you know piece of cake so um
i i like ty lou's attitude i think that
the
the critiques are justified and
like i'm just so interested in how the
clippers respond and how they play
because i think
like i said i think they're the most
talented team in the west
um and i think they should feel that way
and have that confidence
but it's got to be backed with action
before i let you go jeff van gundy what
a moving
weekend it was at the uh the hall of
fame um
and watching everybody go in from
obviously
duncan and kg who you coached against
rudy tom janovich who you
eventually succeeded as rockets coach
and then of course there's kobe bryant
and
and others that went in do you have a
great kobe story that you can share with
us your favorite kobe story whether it
was coaching against him or broadcasting
one of his games
jeff well i think i i love coaching
against him because
great players like duncan and garnett
a they humble you because even when you
have what you think is solid plan
they can you know rip that plan to
shreds but
um i was broadcasting and it was one of
the years
i don't know if it was the year it must
have been the year the celtics beat him
what was that 208 2008
um and i had said kobe was first team
all defense
and uh in game one i said um
i thought kobe would be on my
first team all last all last five
minutes of a close game
defensive team but all defense
i don't think you know because he's had
so much on him to score
i don't think he deserved to be on the
all defense right i said i think shane
battier who i coached in
houston should have been so before game
two
um uh we're going to interview you know
players and coaches and
and bryant is in there or brian is gonna
is coming in
and he walks around the hall and he
walks in and
he says i can't i can't wait till you
come
back to coaching because i'm going to
even
shut your best player down i promise you
that in the first game
and it was great how he went back at me
for critiquing his defense
that's the thing i loved about bryant
like bryant
everything was personal everything was a
challenge
um i loved coaching against him i
appreciated him
for the love of the game and the
competition and
uh you know he was a you know he was one
of the
he was the last of a breed of workhorses
who you know played every game and
played through
things that you know it's not we're not
going to see it again and i
i just appreciate him for the for
getting the numbers for this the great
competitor he was
he has no load managing kobe bryant so
uh what what did you say to him when he
said that to you in that meeting
what did you respond we're going right
at you the first five plays because i
know you're not guarding all five plays
come on and he had a few more choice
words for me but
you know what the thing that i i was
told this
like i think or i read it you know be uh
try hard not to offend try even harder
not to be easily offended
right and like kobe bryant even though
i didn't like i don't know him well um
you know just competition uh
great respect for him and his greatness
um but like you could say stuff like
that to him
and you didn't feel like you know you
you weren't trying to offend and he
wasn't easily offended
but you could you could banter back and
forth um
and he and again he didn't have like
delicate feelings so it was it was to me
it was easy to talk to him
um even though i didn't know i'm great
jeff really appreciate the call
as always look for my call throughout
these playoffs that uh
uh that will i guess begin uh officially
once the plane tournament's over since
this technically isn't a playoff game
that said i will be with the rest of the
country watching you tonight
so thank you all right take care richard
all right that's jeff van gundy
from the worldwide leader in sports
warriors lakers tipping off tonight
with jeff and the rest of the gang on
the call hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here